if you're visiting Hong Kong here are
some of the geekiest places to get your
toys and collectibles we're here at the
Bangkok district and our first stop is
the ctma center where you can find a mix
of Japanese and Western toys and
collectibles just check out this
fighting armor Avengers they look so
awesome and even if you're not buying
you can stay amazed just by window
shopping with the awesome shop front
displays now next is 0 Center food with
toy shops in the upper levels and even
the basement this is where you can find
gacha's trading cards Toys video games
action figures and so much more and if
you're a fan of Lego then you have to
check out in this point these shops
would probably have the model you want
and the prices are actually the cheapest
in the world probably because it's
tax-free in Hong Kong so don't miss out
on the opportunity on getting your
favorite Lego sets there are plenty more
things to see and do here in Hong Kong
so follow us for more Adventures
[Music]